I was either stranded in here, ALONE, with this likely predator...
Or stranded out there in the middle of a lockdown...
Hello, and welcome to Al Dente Creepypasta,
horror stories cooked to perfection with a
splash of red sauce My name is CZ and I will
be your server this episode.
Morning classes with horrible teachers are
hard enough to get through without an insane
clown on the loose in the school.
Today’s story takes us through the worst
day of school.
Let’s dig right in.
“I heard he has a thing going on with that
girl...
Gina Wendelvon!” she half-whispered.
We were sitting in the back of 2nd period
science as my best friend Lexi spilled the
tea on the latest rumors about Mr. Markham,
the history teacher slash volleyball coach
who’s been the subject of some pretty messed
up rumors as of late.
Lexi: “Leslie Franklin was supposedly upstairs
getting something from her locker after practice
one night, and saw Gina coming out from a
“private tutoring session” with Mr. Markham!”
“Eww!
Why the hell would Gina even want to?”
Lexi: “She must REALLY need an A in US History.”
“That’s so gross!
Eww, eww, eww, no!
He’s old.”
Lexi: “From what I heard, she wouldn’t
be the first.”
What she was telling me was, sadly, probably
true.
The rumors about Mr. Markham had swirled into
a frenzy since the winter break incident,
when he had supposedly given Kim Ichikawa
a ride home after the last Volleyball practice
while her parents were gone.
The bell rang.
“Do you think it’s true though?”
Lexi asked me, as I dropped off my science
textbook in my locker, exchanging it for my
US History book.
“I don’t know, why don’t you ask him?”
I told her mockingly.
We both had Mr. Markham next period together.
“I bet you could find out Evanna.
I think he likes you!”
“Eww…
No…
And once again: Eww!”
“He does call on you a lot.
Like a lot a lot.”
“Nope . Don’t care.”
Evanna: “Darn it!
Not again!”
The locker had snagged a bit of the skirt
I was wearing and it was pinched inside my
locker door.
Lexi: “Come on, we’re gonna be late!”
“You could be like a school hero.
Expose him for what he really is and get him
fired!”
We were sitting IN Mr. Markham’s class now,
and I didn’t want to have this discussion
with him in the room.
She was right though.
Of the four students that he had “randomly”
called on this lesson, three of them were
me.
“Lexi, can we please have this discussion
some other--”
Mr Markham: “Evanna!
You’re not talking during my lecture now
are you?”
My heart skipped a beat.
Had he overheard us talking about him?
Mr Markham: “If you have something to say
about District of Columbia v. Heller, why
don’t you share it with the class?”
“No, I don’t sir.”
He paused and stared at me for a moment before
continuing his lesson.
Really?
In front of the whole class?
He must really be getting cocky.
“Thanks a lot…”
I muttered to Lexi.
Mr Markham: “Evanna!
See me after the bell!”
The whole class ‘ooed’ at this, and I
rolled my eyes.
Great.
The last thing I wanted was to be one-on-one
with the biggest creep teacher in the school.
When class let out, Lexi told me she’d wait
out for me in the hall.
Mr. Markham waited for the whole class to
empty out, then closed the door.
I remained at my desk.
He didn’t say anything at first.
He took his time walking over and sitting
on the desk directly in front of me.
He stared at me for a moment, then sighed,
as if he were still contemplating whether
or not he was going to punish me.
The silence was uncomfortable.
Then he went into this rant, about how he
was supposedly concerned with my performance
lately, how it was reflected by behaviour
in class.
It was all bull.
He wouldn’t shut up though.
He was going to make me late for my next class
at this point.
I saw Lexi waiting outside the door.
I wanted to signal her to just go on without
me, but her back was turned.
Mr Markham: “This is exactly the kind of
thing I’m talking about!
Are you even paying attention?”
“I just…”
He interrupted me.
He started asking me all these questions.
Is there something going on with my life?
Is there something wrong at home?
The passing period ended, but he told me he’d
write me a pass to my next class.
Then things started getting really weird.
He started asking personal questions.
If there’s something else distracting me.
If I had a boyfriend.
I needed to get out of here.
I made up some story about being overwhelmed
by my school work.
I don’t know why I thought that would get
him to let me go, but I think it had the opposite
effect, so I froze for a moment, then stood
up out of my chair.
He gets to his feet as well, with a scary
look in his eyes.
Before it could escalate any further, an announcement
comes over the intercom.
“Attention!
Attention!
All classes are hereby suspended into lockdown.
ALL classes are hereby suspended into lockdown!”
It took probably about 15 seconds for the
reality of the situation to sink in…
I was either stranded in here, alone... with
this likely predator… or stranded out there,
alone… in the middle of a lockdown.
Mr. Markham told me to get against the wall
near the door as he turned off the lights.
He came and sat RIGHT next to me on the floor.
Uncomfortably so.
My head was spinning out of control.
That’s when I realized… the door!
Nobody had locked the door!
I looked to the door and realized, there was
someone standing RIGHT on the other side of
it.
Not daring to budge or make a sound, I tried
to conceal my breathing, taking slow deep
breaths.
The footsteps stopped in front of the door.
I was shaking.
But the room was quiet.
*door handle sound*
Whoever was standing out there, had tried
to get in.
The door was ALREADY locked.
I didn’t know if I should be relieved to
safe or outraged that Mr. Markham had LOCKED
ME IN to our conversation after class.
The intruder continued to stand outside the
door.
Then suddenly…
*SMASH*
The entire room seemed to shake as the guy
threw his body against the door!
He tried this a second time before the sound
of a girl screaming could be heard from down
the hall.
What happened next took the horrors I had
experienced up to that point, and twisted
them into something ten times more terrifying.
The guy on the other side of the door, started
blowing this clown horn, over and over.
The sound drifted away from our door and toward
the screaming girl who continued to shriek
and call for help.
*screams, clown horn*
I looked to Mr. Markham as if to suggest he
should go out there and try to help this girl.
He avoided my eye contact.
Freaking coward!
*big bang*
All at once, the screaming and the clown horn
stopped at the sound of a thud.
I gasped, because the severity of the situation
had hit me.
This wasn’t just another drill, this is
the real thing.
What schools all across the country practice
lockdowns for… was this...
This person, this intruder with the clown
horn wasn’t just pulling some kind of joke…
he was dangerous.
My mind went to a dark place: a worst possible
scenario.
And it hit me hard.
My eyes started to blur with tears.
I buried my head in my hands, just trying
to focus on taking deep breaths.
THEN I FELT A COLD PAIR OF HANDS ON MY SHOULDERS.
...and they started to caress me.
That mother****ing pig.
He was using this HORRIBLE situation to his
advantage.
He was trying to take advantage of me at my
most vulnerable moment.
And maybe the worst part was that I was trapped.
I couldn’t make even a sound without putting
my own life in danger.
At this point, I didn’t care anymore.
I didn’t care about the lockdown, the intruder,
any of it.
I needed to get out of this room... now!
I pulled away from his grip and ran to the
door, leaving him alarmed, but he wasn’t
quick enough to stop me, I unlocked it and
slipped out into the empty hallway.
I didn’t really have much of a plan, other
than to hide.
I looked left.
Further down the hall, a girl was lying unconscious
on the floor with a guy in a black and white
clown suit standing over her.
He didn’t seem to have noticed me.
I looked to the right.
An empty hallway.
Rows of lockers.
And one trash can.
I didn’t know if this would work, but I
didn’t really have another option.
I quietly ran to my right, jumped, and landed
in the trash can, trying to make as little
noise as possible.
Lucky for me, the can was mostly empty, so
I was able to crouch down and not be seen
poking out the top.
It was quiet for a moment…
Then… the clown horn started repeatedly
honking again…
It was gradually getting louder, which meant
the clown was headed in my direction.
My hiding spot was about to be tested.
The clown yanked the rim of the garbage can,
and sending me tumbling out onto the floor!
A pair of big, shiny, obsidian black eyes
was staring down as the clown stood over me
with a disgusting grin.
It was the face of an old style circus clown.
He must have been wearing blackout contacts
or something and his face was completely greased
down in white makeup, except for his lips
and the dots on his cheeks, both of which
were painted black.
In fact, his entire outfit was black and white,
making him look like he had stepped out of
a black and white photograph and into reality.
The only part that did look more cartoonish
was how very bloodthirsty his grin was.
I was lying on my back on the floor where
I had been dumped out of the garbage can as
this horrifying thing reached down for me.
I only knew of one thing left to do.
As hard as I could I kicked my foot up into
his balls!
But to my shock and horror, this attack did
nothing to him!
The clown didn’t even flinch.
It seemed to cause him no pain whatsoever.
I felt his silk gloves close around my neck
as he pinned me to the ground.
I tried to scream, but I felt my throat close
up, and I knew it would do me no good anyway.
All I could do was look up at this circus
drawn nightmare and… and there was something
else…..
Just above my head was someone’s overstuffed
locker.
It wasn’t fully closed; the bottom of the
door was pushed open by some object that didn’t
quite fit inside, but it looked like the owner
had tried to cram it shut anyhow.
I reached for the locker door and yanked at
it.
It gave a little bit, but it was stuck.
I was starting to blackout.
If I could just pull it free…
I gave it a hard tug and pulled on it.
My vision was fading, almost entirely black
now.
I maybe only realized it had worked when I
heard the familiar sound of the locker flying
open, and it crashed against the clown’s
head, knocking it backwards and off of me.
An unbelievable amount of junk came pouring
out.
Whatever was in there must have been heavy,
because it had really knocked the clown hard
in the head, which was good because I also
needed a moment to come to.
I had one more idea -- if this didn’t work,
I was done for.
As fast as I could, I took all of the junk
out of the locker and hurled it at the clown.
Textbooks, an instrument case, a pair of shoes;
anything I could find.
The clown seemed woozy and it got back to
its feet and regained its bearings just as
I threw my last piece of ammo.
It seemed like none of the junk in that locker
was big enough to hurt the clown which didn’t
seem to even feel or notice anything other
than the blow to it’s head.
But hurting it wasn’t my plan.
I had completely emptied out the locker.
This was it.
Do or die.
I stepped back into the locker as the clown,
with a twisted face of anger and frustration,
charged at me as I pulled the door shut as
much as possible without pinching my hand!
Everything went black as I shut myself into
the locker and furious clown slammed into
the door, effectively locking me in!
There was no scream or roar of frustration,
just the echoey reverberation of the clown
crashing up against the metal door.
He fumbled with the handle shortly before
realizing that it was no good.
Then I heard something move in the distance,
and the clown started beeping it’s horn
once again, and heading off to some other
part of the school.
I stayed safe in the that locker for hours
until the school was cleared and the principal
used his master key to let me out.
The light hurt my eyes as I collapsed onto
the hallway floor; I had been limited to the
tiny amount of light that poured through three
thin slots on the locker door.
The principal gave me a little nod, and told
me, “good thinking”, or something along
those lines, before turning and attending
to the more important matters at hand.
The hallway was now filled with police officers,
school administrators, news reporters, photographers…
and… wait, what were Lexi’s parents doing
here?
My best friend’s dad was standing maybe
15 feet down the hall with his arm around
her mom, who was sobbing and dabbing at her
eyes as the commotion flowed around them like
a rock cutting through a stream.
What? What had happened?
I looked around some more and realized they
weren’t the only ones.
It looked like there were a few more sets
of parents in tears scattered around the hallway
here and there.
There were no other students around, I guess
the rest of the day’s classes had cancelled.
Before I got up from off the floor where I
had fallen out of the locker, I noticed a
little ripped piece of fabric fall on the
ground right where I fell.
It looked like it had been a piece of the
clown’s neck ruffle that had been caught
in the closing locker door and probably ripped
off when it tried to escape.
There was text on it.
It said “...ipsey and Parks...”
The rest was torn off and I couldn’t read
it.
A bright flash filled the room.
Reporters were taking pictures of Mr. Markham,
but to my surprise, he wasn’t being handcuffed
or interrogated by angry parents.
A news anchor wearing a tie and holding a
microphone started to praise him; going on about
this one brave teacher whose heroics may have
saved the lives of countless students.
Then he started going into this phony story
about how he immediately ran out to fight
off the clown and protect the students the
moment the lockdown is called.
Yeah, right, you’ve got to be kidding me!
I was too drained to care though.
I was crammed in a locker with no food and
not a big slot for air, and I really felt
like I was going to black out again.
I took a seat back down on the floor and closed
my eyes for a minute.
Mr. Markham finished up his interview and
the reporter wrapped up the story.
“This is the second clown attack our nation
has seen this week, after two students at
a school in Garden Coast -- just yesterday
-- were fortunately unharmed during a lockdown
incident.
For CZN News 23, I’m Poppy Harlowe.”
I looked around at the devastation surrounding
me.
The incident was obviously over, but I still
felt this huge pit in my stomach, as if nothing
had been resolved.
Two clown attacks in one week?
Sure the other school was probably nowhere
near here, but still.
All the reporters and police officers seemed
to just be going about their business, as
if this were just part of their routine or
something.
Where was the urgency?
Why wasn’t anyone doing anything about this?
For a moment I got really angry, but then
the anger was just replaced with pain.
My heart slowly broke as I sat there.
I couldn’t get Lexi’s mom’s face out
of my head…
Would I ever see Lexi again?
Would school ever be the same?
I’m pretty sure I knew the answer to both
questions when my parents arrived to pick
me up.
Both of their eyes were swollen and red...
Thanks for listening to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Your total comes out to $23.00 but if you
like this video right now I’ll waive that
fee and give you everything you just listened
to absolutely free.
Big thanks for Spirit Voices for narrating
this episode, definitely go check out her
channel.
Other guest narrators include Penny Tailsup
and Ruustic B. I highly recommend you check
out their channels.
Click the playlist on the left to check out
every other creepy clown school lockdown incident
and remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming, we both survive.